all right we are back with Donald J
Trump we're outside of beautiful Des
Moines Iowa for the hour we will be
taking questions from the audience
and tonight as the 24-24 race heats up
president Trump and other Republican
candidates are now crisscrossing the
state and of course the former president
has a commanding lead in both Iowa and
nationally the GOP field though is
growing last week Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis threw his hat in the ring and
soon we expect that uh former vice
president Mike Pence will be in uh
anti-trump Zealot Chris Christie will
join in and but can anyone close the gap
let's talk about well I guess we're up
to nine people after next week
um
that's a good thing isn't it I think
pretty good but I don't think it matters
uh I don't know why people are doing it
they're at one percent some are at zero
I hear Chris Christie's coming in he
he's at
he was at 6
in New Jersey which is I love New Jersey
but six percent approval rating in New
Jersey what's the purpose and he's he's
polling at zero and uh uh others are I
call them Ada Hutchinson I don't call
him as I call him Ada Hutchinson I gave
her a little name for some reason for
certain reasons but this guy nobody
knows who the hell he is never never
good
and some you know it's fine but I don't
understand what they're doing now maybe
there's something wrong but when you're
at one percent or less you know one
percent it says one percent with an
arrow pointing left there's one guy
who's at zero with an arrow pointing
left that means he's at less than zero
so uh it is what it is you know I I
really go after the one who's second and
I think the one who's second is going
down so much and so rapidly that I don't
think he's going to be second that much
longer I think he's going to be third or
fourth
he had a very bad day that he got very
angry at the Press
not allowed to get angry at the Press
let me let me
at the fake news he got angry
so you probably became in history the
most investigative president of all time
times ten okay
so
but if my poll numbers went down it
would all end
you know every time my poll goes up I
say oh this is problem but we had a poll
today that showed I was
44 points above number two and beating
Biden
and beating Biden by 11 points beating
Biden by 11 points and beating Biden by
15 and 16 points in some of them and
he's not doing well against Biden let me
let me ask you because you are because
we can't take a chance of this election
I think a lot of people agree with that
I don't I don't think things have been
as bad it turned so badly so quickly the
third issue is there's a special counsel
that's appointed and news broke
yesterday that there might be a tape
recording that a quote where you
acknowledge that you understood that
these were classified documents first of
all do you know who this call may be
with do you know anything no I don't
know anything about it all I know is
this
right we have the presidential records
act which I abided by a hundred percent
Biden has
1850 boxes with a lot of classified
stuff that he's not supposed to have in
his case I have the right to declassify
as president he's got 1850 boxes that he
doesn't want anyone to see he had seven
or eight boxes in Chinatown in
Washington DC where nobody even speaks
English in Chinatown Chinatown is very
it's it's in favor of China and he has
boxes in Chinatown they took those boxes
and they sent them to Boston to his
lawyer so his lawyer can look through
them and probably do things that you're
not supposed to do no this is about
election interference and in fact I have
to tell you uh dershowitz and a couple
of very good guys wrote an article today
uh the Tobacco King you know who the
Tobacco King He did great job on the
tobacco companies they wrote an article
today that this is a disgrace that
they're even looking at this stuff they
would was nothing done wrong nothing
whatsoever now look at the boxes with
Biden where they're in his garage
they're all over the floor they're
sitting under his Corvette with the
grease and everything else on a garage
door that you could cut with a scissor
and no secret service I have Secret
Service all over the place Mar-A-Lago is
a fort it's literally you know she built
that as a southern white house but when
you look at it and it's another it's a
continuation of the greatest Witch Hunt
of all time it's a hoax and it has to do
it has to do
more than anything else with trying to
interfere with the election and let me
tell you doj actually took you talk
about Bragg the D.A of New York I never
thought I'd be dealing with a guide like
this you talk about Bragg the doj in
Washington put his top guy into the DA's
office which is local which is city
state but they put the top guy in the
Justice Department into that office to
make sure Trump gets in trouble can you
believe it it's never ever happened
before and then
Hillary Clinton's lawyer from I guess
it's Paul Weiss
left Paul Weiss to work in the
prosecutor's office because he hates
Trump and he wants to get Trump and then
nobody wanted to do anything because
they say you know Trump didn't do
anything wrong it's Ludy Bragg
originally said Trump didn't do anything
wrong and then he prosecutes for what
what he said was not wrong but they took
this guy they took this guy and they put
him in there and he left the firm and he
went in it's a big you know pomerance
Mock pomeranz and he left to become a
prosecutor he was a Democrat lawyer and
now he's trying to prosecute me and then
what happened is they wouldn't do what
he wanted to do because it was too bad
even for them
so this guy left and he writes a book
during the process they tell me what he
did is Criminal they tell me now let's
see what happens
but he's in a lot of trouble so here's a
prosecutor left and he wrote a book
during a prosecution but I've been going
through this for seven years Russia
Russia Russia all of it the Mueller
report which was no collusion after two
and a half years there was no collusion
with Russia
I was the worst thing Putin would say
you know they say you like me he said
you are the worst guy that we've ever
had to deal with I'm the one that
stopped the pipeline the uh the big
pipeline going up to Germany I stopped
it when Biden came in it's called
Nordstrom too when Nordstrom two nobody
ever heard of it until I came along I
said you're allowing Russia to build a
pipeline through Europe I stopped it it
was stopped dead
and then the election came about and
Biden came in one of the first things he
did was allow Russia to complete the
pipeline I had to stop and then they say
I'll tell you what they're a party of
disinformation they'll say Trump is soft
though in Russia I'm the hardest on
Russia that there's ever been the
sanctions we did everything else and I
got along
[Applause]
and by the way the hardest on China by a
factor I took in hundreds of billions of
dollars from China and as I said no
other president ever took in 10 cents
and you know what China respected us and
president XI respected your president
and he didn't want to have any more
tariffs and he didn't want to have any
more sanctions but he respected us and
now he doesn't respect they don't even
return phone calls you know abortion now
is back as a real campaign issue
um and then issues I didn't think when I
started my radio career in 1987 I'd be
talking a lot about but education
kids gender identity classes CRT I never
thought we'd really have this deep
debate about whether or not biological
men could be playing in women's sports
when you're so crazy on all of these
issues you know what is the best way
that you see to settle well I did
something that nobody thought was
possible I got rid of Roe v Wade and by
doing that
by doing that
it put pro-lifers in a very strong
negotiating position now they're
negotiating different things and you
know I happen to be of the Ronald Reagan
School in terms of uh exemptions where
you have the life of the mother rape and
Princess mother's life so you have that
and I think you know for me that's
something that works very well and for
probably 80 85 percent because don't
forget we do have to win elections but I
did something that nobody could do and I
also made them the radicals because they
are willing and able to kill babies in
the ninth month they're willing to kill
babies that's radical pro-life isn't
radical they've made pro-life radical
the other side pro-life is not radical
what's radical is killing a baby in the
eighth month the seventh month the ninth
month or even the babies after the
baby's born and
and you know unfortunately we have a lot
of politicians and you saw that in the
midterms I think it was a big factor
that didn't really know how to talk
about what we did with Roe v Wade and
what we did on pro-life they didn't know
how to talk about it and it energized
the Democrats and they used that I mean
they used that as a commercial you
wouldn't believe it what what should but
especially when you didn't have the
exceptions when you didn't have the
exceptions they went after the people
like viciously The Edge and those people
did not generally speaking they didn't
do very well in terms of election but
when when you have the exceptions and
you go through the whole the whole gamut
it's something that's an incredible
thing but one thing it really did though
Sean is it gave people that are pro-life
a great power to negotiate we had no
power to negotiate because you had
Roe v Wade sitting in there where you
could do anything where the other side
could do anything they can't do that
right now so we're in a great position
to negotiate something really really
good and most people
I think really respect what we did now I
will say every once in a while I'll
watch somebody say I did more for uh
abortion on abortion and abortion rights
and pro-life I did more than some well
only stupid people would say that
because everyone said there was no way
that Roe v Wade was going to disappear
but because because it was very unfair
the other thing is people wanted to
bring it back to the States I consider
that less important but nevertheless a
lot of people want to bring them back
this brings it back to the States more
with Donald Trump and we'll hear from
our Iowa hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else